have got this equation over here
although it is not mentioned in the
question that what type of this equation
so basically this is a quadratic
equation if you will simplify then
you'll get that it's a quadratic
equation this simpler logic over here is
to take the variable over here on the
left hand side and subtract if you
simplify like that you'll be able to do
it quickly you see this is 2A plus b
plus 2X and minus 1 by 2x over here not
of this whole expression in the left
hand side I can take X plus a as common
so you see I'll be getting X plus a and
inside the other bracket will be left
with 4X plus 2B 4X plus 2B and that is
equal to 0 over here so what are the two
roots of this quadratic equation guys I
can say that X will be equal to minus a
and the other thing will be minus 2B
upon 4.